[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
ihr Lieben heute geht es um ein
Verbrechen wie man das in Büchern oder
Film wohl eher selten finden wird
Stefan findest du ich meine hier werden
Leute nach Mafia Manier erschossen und
um organisierte Kriminalität da geht's
doch auch oder ja zugegeben einiges
davon ist vielleicht filmreif aber was
ich meine ist das in Mafia Streifen oder
Psycho Trailern das sind alle bösen
meist total schlau die Taten sind total
intelligent die Mordpläne brillant und
die Dialoge gewitzt weißt du okay ich
verstehe ich weiß worauf du hinaus
willst okay also heute geht es um einen
Dreifachmord in der
nordrhein-westfälischen Provinz und die
Täter sind genauso groß und brutal wie
sie komplett dämlich sind bei dem was
sie geplant und getan haben war einfach
mal gar nichts gewitzt oder perfide das
meinte ich ich bin übrigens Stefan Netze
Band und ich bin Mirko Kasimir und der
Fall der uns heute beschäftigt hat im
Jahr 2003 unseren Chef Reporter Frank
Schneider aus dem Schlaf gerissen der
uns übrigens auch heute wieder
unterstützt der Frank Schneider er muss
an das putzfrauen-massaker von Telgte so
war damals die Schlagzeile im Bild ist
eins der wirklich brutalsten
sinnlosesten Verbrechen was ich in 33
Jahren als Polizeireporter gesehen habe
es war nachts irgendwann kam die
Alarmierung dort liegen drei Frauen
hinter einem Fitnessstudio erschossen
mit Kopfschüssen regelrecht hingerichtet
an dem Hinterausgang und keiner konnte
sich das erstmal überhaupt erklären
diese drei Frauen war nicht miteinander
verwandt haben eben da zusammen geputzt
waren die Putzfrauen von diesem
Fitnessstudio und diese Liquidierung wie
bei der Mafia passt überhaupt nicht ins
Bild das Verbrechen erschüttert ein
Idyll denn die 20.000 Einwohner Stadt
Telgte liegt 12 km von Münster entfernt
malerisch an der Ems zu den
Sehenswürdigkeiten gehören eine
Wallfahrtskapelle einer der ältesten
Bäume Deutschlands und die
Propsteikirche St Clemens aber in der
Zeit des 28 januar 2003 ist von dieser
Idylle am Fluss nichts zu sehen und das
liegt nicht nur an der Tageszeit er die
Tat war kurz vor Mitternacht wir haben
dann am frühen Morgen davon erfahren und
ich kann mich noch erinnern als ich da
ankam es war im Winter es war noch
dunkel die Leichen lagen noch dort die
Spurensicherung lief noch und dieses
Entsetzen in den Gesichtern der
Polizisten das waren relativ junge
Frauen die Waren 30/34 und 39 wenn ich
mich richtig erinnere und man wusste zu
dem Zeitpunkt natürlich auch schon man
hatte ja die Verwandten schon informiert
dass sie ebenso viele Kinder auch
hinterlassen 5 minderjährige Kinder und
das war ein solches Entsetzen in den
Gesichtern auch dieses Gefühl zu haben
was ist denn jetzt hier passiert wieso
tötet man drei Putzfrau nach der Arbeit
mit Kopfschüssen richtet die dorthin
exekutiert die regelrecht das war damals
auch bei den Polizisten wirklich so das
Gefühl was ist hier nur passiert und das
hat mich damals wirklich total
beeindruckt im negativen Sinne
bei den Toten handelt es sich um die
drei Reinigungskräfte Linda m damals 34
Jahre alt Conny m 39 sowie die
30-Jährige Sengül D die drei haben
gerade ihre Spätschicht in einem
Fitnessstudio beendet und sind auf dem
Parkplatz dabei sich zu verabschieden es
ist 23:40 Uhr dann tritt ein Mann mit
einer Sturmhaube auf dem Kopf und einer
Waffe zu Ihnen und sagt geht mal alle an
die Wand die Frauen machen was ihnen
gesagt wird dann sagt der Mann noch tut
mir leid und erschießt die drei Kollegen
mit seiner neuen mm Pistole er drückt
dreimal ab ohne zu zögern ohne Zweifel
ohne Gruppe von rechts nach links danach
verlässt er den Tatort zügig aber ohne
Hektik zu Fuß wir erklären euch auch
noch wieso der Ablauf so genau bekannt
ist
aber der Chef der Mordkommission Werner
Brökers und seine Kollegen haben in
dieser Nacht und an den ersten Tagen
keine direkte Spur der sie nachgehen
können keine Aussagen über irgendein
Fluchtauto oder gar dessen Kennzeichen
keine Aufnahmen einer Überwachungskamera
keine direkten Zeugen obwohl die Morde
wie eine Art Mafia Hinrichtung
durchgeführt wurden vermuten die Beamten
schnell einen persönliches Motiv eine
Tat aus dem direkten Umfeld einer der
drei Frauen also gehört auch der Ehemann
des jüngsten Opfers Samuel D zu den
Verdächtigen hüssein.de damals 31 Jahre
alt genauer gesagt sind die Ermittler in
ihm sogar frühzeitig einen
Hauptverdächtigen aber sie wiegen ihn in
Sicherheit Füße ihn D darf in die Türkei
reisen um dort bei der Beisetzung seiner
Frau dabei zu sein
nur drei Tage nach der Tat reist er zu
Beerdigung von Sengül ab und er fühlt
sich offenbar tatsächlich sicher denn
zwei Wochen später kehrt er artig nach
Telgte zurück aus der Sicht eines
Verbrechers war das ein Fehler denn in
der Zwischenzeit hatte sich seinen
24-jähriger komplizierte Timo jean-öl
bereits in Widersprüche verstrickt und
die Polizei so auf die Spur des
Ehemannes geführt das heißt auf die Spur
von hussein.de und dessen Motiv das so
wahnsinnig und so dumm war dass es eben
wie am Anfang geschildert für keinen
Mafia Film taugt Frank Schneider
erinnert sich an seine eigene
Fassungslosigkeit die Polizei ist denen
auf die Schliche gekommen weil man sehr
schnell das Gefühl hatte das stimmt
irgendwas nicht da muss es Hintergründe
geben und dieser türkische Ehemann war
sich seiner Sache sehr sicher und muss
wohl auch mit seinen Komplizen
telefoniert haben es gab also diesen
jungen Killer den er engagiert hat und
es gab noch einen weiteren Mann auch
erst 24 Jahre alt der auch mehr oder
weniger wegen Beihilfe später verurteilt
worden ist die hat nämlich den Plan
zusammen ein Bordell zu eröffnen und das
wahnsinnige dabei war man hatte zwar dem
jungen Schützen 5000 Euro in Aussicht
gestellt die hat aber nie bekommen
eigentlich war der Lohn für diesen
Dreifachmord er dürfte dann als
Türsteher in diesem zukünftigen wollte
arbeiten das war im Endeffekt der Anreiz
für ihn diese unglaubliche Tat zu
begehen er hatte später vor Gericht auch
ausgesagt er war schon am Tag vorher
einmal da hat sich dann nicht getraut
und dann hat aber der Ehemann so ein
Druck auf ihn ausgeübt und du weißt
jetzt auch zu viel du musst das jetzt
machen dass er noch mal hingefahren in
der Nacht danach und hat er hinter vor
Gericht erzählt das war echt dramatisch
die Frau noch gesagt was wollen sie von
uns haben kein Geld was soll das und
dann hat er zu dir gesagt geht da mal
rüber an die Wand da mussten sie mit dem
Gesichtern zur Wand hinstellen und dann
hat er sie er hat kürzester Zeit alle
mit Kopfschüssen getötet
Werbung servus hier spricht Christian
Gerüchte rund um den FC Bayern jeden
Freitag kommt und ich nehme euch hinter
die Kulissen des Rekordmeisters
Werbung Ende also nochmal langsam der
möchtegern auf josu hüssein.de will
seine Frau loswerden sie steht ihm bei
seinen Plänen im Weg er hat gleich auf
mehrfache Weise Angst dass sie seine
Pläne verrät dass eine Trennung von ihr
Schande bedeuten könnte dass die Familie
seiner Frau ihn attackiert er beauftragt
seinen 24-Jährigen Kumpanen und einen
Helfer die Frau umzubringen und um vom
Motiv und den Tätern abzulenken konnte
auf die Idee hey wir killen einfach auch
noch die beiden Kollegen meiner Frau
dann kommt keiner auf unsere Spur das
ist so grausamlich ist als wäre das
alles nicht traurig genug war auch noch
eine weitere Frauengeschichte im Spiel
dazu noch mal Frank Schneider der hatte
auch eine Geliebte der hat einen
regelrechtes Doppelleben geführt der hat
einfach ein komplett anderes Leben
gefühlt und das was er eben in seinem
Kulturkreis wieder das auch immer wieder
nannte geführt hat da passte das alles
nicht rein und er wollte da ausbrechen
er hat aber Angst wenn er sich von
seiner Frau trennt dass es dann zur
Blutrache kommt gegen ihn und hat sich
dann entschieden eben seine Frau töten
zu lassen und wie gesagt das
unglaublichste an den Verbrechen ist
auch dieser Gedanke allein ich verwirr
damit die Polizei dann wissen die nicht
was dahinter steckt und was sie mir auch
hätte klar sein müssen wenn drei Frauen
so schrecklich getötet werden ist
natürlich der Druck der Fahndungsdruck
und der Ermittlungsdruck durch die
Polizei noch immens größer als bei einem
Opfer es dauert keine zwei Wochen bis
die Polizei das unfassbare Verbrechen im
Idyll von Telgte vollständig aufgeklärt
hat der schmale hussi mit der ovalen
Brille gesteht die tötungspläne und wie
er eine Waffe besorgt hat er gibt zu den
Mord an seiner Frau in Auftrag gegeben
zu haben Frank Schneider fast noch mal
zusammen und dann hat sich
herausgestellt im Rahmen der Ermittlung
die Polizei war relativ schnell sicher
da muss es irgendeine beziehungstag
geben sonst macht das alles überhaupt
keinen Sinn
dass der Ehemann der türkischen Putzfrau
die dabei war hinter dieser
schrecklichen Tal steckt dass er ein
killerbeauftragt hat Hintergrund war er
wollte an Bordelle eröffnen er wollte in
den illegalen Menschenhandel einsteigen
und in Drogenhandel und seine Frau
wollte das natürlich nicht in seinem
Kulturkreis so nannte das damals käme
eine Scheidung nicht in Frage also muss
die Frau weg und wie konnte sie anders
weg als sie eben zu töten das war seine
Meinung und hat einen jungen Mann
engagiert selber ist 21 Jahre alt er
soll sie töten und jetzt kommts um die
Polizei zu verwirren sollte er die
anderen beiden Frauen auch töten damit
die nicht wissen worum es geht das heißt
diese Frauen sind so sinnlos gestorben
man hat fünf Kindern die Mutter genommen
und die Ehefrau dieses Türken der das
beauftragt hat war auch noch schwanger
zu dem Zeitpunkt der Tat das heißt also
eigentlich hat man auch noch ein Kind
mit getötet
nach etwas mehr als 14 Tagen also ist
das Verbrechen aufgeklärt und die Täter
gestehen alle nacheinander
Münsters Polizeipräsident Hubert wimba
und der leitende Staatsanwalt Joachim
Wagner bezeichneten dies grobellosigkeit
des dreifachmordes als unfassbar zu
Recht vor allem der Haupttäter Hüfte in
die hat sich völlig in seiner
Skrupellosigkeit verrannt er träumt von
einer Gangster Karriere und einem Leben
mit der 22-jährigen geliebten aus Polen
für sie hatte extra heimlich unter einem
falschen Namen eine Wohnung enthält die
gemietet und um seine Ziele zu erreichen
lässt er seine schwangere Frau abknallen
vor Gericht lässt er durch seinen Anwalt
eine Erklärung verlesen in der er die
Tat in vollem Umfang besteht und sich
bei den Angehörigen der beiden anderen
Opfer entschuldigt sein Auftragskiller
und mit Täter Timo jean-öl sagt aus sein
Freund für sie sei mit einem Problem zu
ihm gekommen
er wolle sich scheiden lassen könne dies
aber nicht weil er dann so wörtlich von
der Frauenseite umgebracht werde Füße
ihn D habe gesagt sie muss weg der
Gerichtsreporter der Süddeutschen
Zeitung schildert die weitere Aussage
von timotinöl so er timocin habe zu dir
gesagt ich werde es probieren du musst
alle Frauen wegmachen antwortet der am
Abend des 24 Januar sei er zum
Fitnessstudio gefahren habe die Frauen
beobachtet dann aber habe ihn der Mut
verlassen die habe ihm jedoch Druck
gemacht am 28 Januar schließlich habe er
die Frauen abgepasst als sie aus dem
Studio kamen habe er gesagt Leute geht
mal rüber in die Wand timocin Öl macht
eine Pause
sein Anwalt flüstert ihm ins Ohr dann
habe ich alle erschossen
und so erinnert sich Bildreporter Frank
Schneider vom Protest kann ich mich nur
erinnern das konnte man ihn noch gar
nicht abnehmen das sind so getan wird
als der den alles ganz Leid und haben
sich entschuldigt ich kann mich auch
noch in den an den jungen Schützen
erinnern der das relativ teilnahmslos so
geschildert hat wo man sich gedacht hat
wie kann einer der auch vorher nicht
großartig vorbestraft war also den
Körperverletzung glaub Diebstahl aber
nichts wirklich wer weiß wie schlimm ist
wie kann der so agieren und dann auch
noch mit dieser ja noch nicht mal
wirklich was dafür bekommen er schildert
das immer so habe selber Angst gehabt
dass er sonst selber Bücher Weise
Probleme kriegen würde und er hinterher
auf der abschlussliste Stände aber das
war schon ein Prozess wo man auch
gemerkt hat wir haben damals auch
gedacht dass das möglicherweise auch im
Gefängnis noch mal so Blutrache führt
weil natürlich die Hinterblieben in der
anderen Opfer es war eine deutsche Frau
und eine albanische Frau die Familie
natürlich auch alle völlig geschockt
immer noch waren auch voll ja Rache
gelösten kann man sagen was man total
nachvollziehen kann wie kann man eine
solche Tat begehen besonders weil die
anderen beiden Frauen ja völlig sinnlos
gestorben sind am ersten August 2003
fällt am Land nicht Münster das Urteil
Auftraggeber hüssein D und Killer
timucinö müssen lebenslang in Haft
außerdem wird die besondere Schwere der
Schuld festgestellt als dritter wird der
Helfer alid zu 8 Jahren Haft verurteilt
hüssein D sagt am Ende die verdiente
Strafe wird mich nicht von meiner Schuld
vor Gott befreien der Richter fasst den
Fall so zusammen das war keine
Beziehungstat aus Verzweiflung das war
monatelange miniziöse Planung
[Musik]
das war unser Fall für heute wir haben
ihn mit Frank Schneider und seinen
Unterlagen erzählt so wie zwei guten
Artikel aus der Süddeutschen Zeitung und
der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung die
Links dazu findet ihr in den Show Notes
Skript Aufnahme und schnitt Stefan
Netzeband Postproduktion weight watch
Studios München vielen Dank dass ihr
wieder dabei wart und bis zum nächsten
Mal euer Mirko und euer Stefan